مر اصعب يوم على اسرائيل منذ بدء حربها
على غزه اسبوع عنوانه عمليه مخيم المغازي
وسجل جديد لقتلى جيش الاحتلال الله اكبر
ولله الحمد باذن الله قتله باذن الله جنود
يسقطون في كمائن ويصرخون خوفا من الموت
واخرون يعودون الى اسرهم في صناديق
خشبيه ضربه واحده لكتائب القسام قتلت 21
عسكريا بعد تفجير منزل تحصنت فيه قوه
اسرائيليه في عمليه وصفت بالمركبه شرق
مخيم المغازي تزامن هذا مع تدمير دبابه
ميركافا كانت تؤمن القوه المتحصن في
المنزل بقذيفه الياسين 105 فكانت النتيجه
مقتل 24 عسكريا حدث لم يكن عاديا على
الصعيدين العسكري والسياسي دفع رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي هيرسي هاليفي الى فتح
تحقيق ميداني وعزز موقف [__] الحرب ولا
سما اسر المحتجزين الذين اقتحموا اجتماعا
للجنه الماليه بالكنيس لكن نتنياهو
المحاصر بهاجس الفشل والملاحقات القانونيه
حسب وصف صحيفه لاكوا الفرنسيه جدد اصراره
على مواصله الحرب مع ان احدث التقديرات
لصحيفه الروسل بوست تؤكد ان جيش اسرائيل
لم يعد بوسعه تحقيق انجازات استراتيجيه
بغزه بعد ضربه
المغازي
عداد الشهداء في غزه لم يهدا هذا الاسبوع
اذ قتلت اسرائيل خلال سته ايام
1252 فلسطينيا معظمهم اطفال ونساء وبلغ
بذلك العدد الاجمالي للشهداء عتبه 26 الف
شهيد اما الجرحى فتجاوز عددهم 64 ال وفق
احدث الاحصاءات وبينما اكدت حركه حماس ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ارتكب جريمه جديده بحق
النازحين بقصفه خمسه مراكز لايواء
النازحين في خان يونس حذرت وزاره الصحه في
غزه من ان الاحتلال يعزل مستشفيات خانيونس
ويرتكب جرائم اباده جماعيه وفي اليوم
العالمي للتعليم احصت وزاره التعليم
الفلسطينيه استشهاد
4300 طالب فلسطيني في غزه في حين اكدت
وكاله الاونر ان اكثر من
625000 طالب حرموا من التعليم منذ بدء
الحرب على غزه تتزامن هذه التطورات مع
الحديث عن مقترح لصفقه جديده قدمته حكومه
نتنياهو لاطلاق سراح الاسرى في غزه مقابل
وقف مؤقت للحرب على القطاع وسط تفاؤل
اسرائيلي حذر لكن حكومه الاحتلال ترفض
مناقشه شروط المقاومه واولها الوقف الدائم
لاطلاق النار الحديث عن صفقه لا ينسجم مع
تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين التي
تزداد تطرفا مع استمرار الحرب اذ اكد
نتنياهو انه ابلغ الولايات المتحده
معارضته اقامه دوله فلسطينيه بعد انتهاء
الحرب في غزه في تصريح ينسف كل الاتفاقيات
الدوليه ذات
الصله الى الواجهه هذا الاسبوع فكره تهجير
سكان غزه اذ طرح وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
زراي كاتس خلال لقاء مع نظرائه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فكره انشاء جزيره صناعيه في مياه
غزه تكون وطنا بديلا للفلسطينيين حسب ما
نقلت صحف اوروبيه وهو ما انكرته لاحقا
وزاره الخارجيه زعمه ان الفكره تتعلق
ببناء ميناء لغزه على جزيره صناعيه هذا
منطق الذي لا وطن له وهذا يؤكد بوضوح ان
هؤلاء الذين جاؤوا الى ارض فلسطين لا
ينتمون الى هذه الارض ولا يعرفون قيمتها
على الصعيد الخارجي لا تبدو اسرائيل احسن
حالا من الداخل فمع استمرار اشتعال الجبهه
الشماليه المحاذيه للبنان اظهرت دراسه
اكاديميه اسرائيليه ان نحو 60% من
المستوطنين النازحين من الشمال يخشون
العوده الى منازلهم وفي اليمن ما تزال سفن
الم المرتبطه باسرائيل ممنوعه من العبور
ومهد رغم تجدد الغارات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه على مواقع لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين هذه العوامل كلها بالاضافه الى
القرار الذي ستصدره محكمه العدل الدوليه
سترسم مسار هذه الحرب وفق تقديرات
المحللين وستضعف موقف اسرائيل المتمسك
باستمرار
العدوان
in they regroup and
rearm